il y a quelque chose de réconfortant ici
après avoir fui l'ukraine anastacia et
sa mère se sont installés ici aleri à
l'ouest de montréal où la guerre ne
pourrait pas semblé plus lointaines
nous
on est bien finalement après deux mois
de stress dit olga
elle se préparait à aller au travail le
jour où la guerre a commencé à
chercher qu'à point que tous nos plans
d'avenir et tous nos projets se sont
envolés à ce moment explique anastacia
et notre vie a complètement chaviré
ça se passe très bien ce sont deux
personnes très facile a rencontré à
discuter
elles sont ouvertes aucun problème avec
elle à son
schéma type pc motif qu'elle
aimait son exception
car moi
anne marie et normand un couple de
retraités les accueillent chez eux dans
les chambres que leurs enfants
occupaient autrefois là j'aurais
anastasia gelé force est allé se coucher
parce qu'elle voulait déjà je regarde
sans cv elle travaillait en production
vidéo à kiev alors que le gars était
professeur de philologie à l'université
moi je suis convaincu que les deux noms
se trouver un travail à la hauteur de
leurs compétences
[Musique]
victoria elle était dentiste en ukraine
arrivé depuis à peine un mois elle a
déjà été engagée dans cette clinique
dentaire de châteauguay
elle était au travail à kiev la veille
des premiers bombardements quand son
mari l'a appelé il voulait partir tout
de suite elle n'est jamais retournée
chez elle
à la maison avec leurs deux jumeaux le
mari de victoria maxime nous dit que la
famille retrouve tranquillement une
certaine normalité dites routières les
enfants s'adaptent très bien dit il il
commence la garderie oui il y a des
moments difficiles mais ils veulent se
refaire une vie ici barbara et wayne qui
les héberge depuis quelques jours les
considèrent déjà comme de la famille des
cépages croquer on fait nos premiers pas
au début on ne comprenait rien avoue
maxime mais on commence à se débrouiller
et qui dit nouvelle vie au québec dit
justement apprendre le français
olga sa fille anastasia et maxime
assistent tous à leur premier cours dans
une classe composée exclusivement de
réfugiés ukrainien
durant huit semaines ils seront ici du
lundi au vendredi la tête dans les
cahiers d'apprentissage
j'avais plusieurs craignant qu'ils
arrivaient sur le territoire à d'un même
coup nicoletta du saphir le service
d'accueil et de formation en immigration
du roussillon s'est chargé de
l'inscription des nouveaux étudiants des
dizaines d'autres n'ont pas eu de place
et devront attendre à l'automne par la
langue passe tous par la langue passe
l'intégration si je ne connais pas la
langue pour moi ça va être complètement
impossible une tête totalement difficile
de m'intégrer dans cette société veut
maîtriser le français les aidera à
trouver un emploi le ministre du travail
indique que plus de 500 entreprises ont
exprimé le souhait d'engager des
ressortissants ukrainiens on connaît
l'environnement crânien les chocs causés
par la guerre par l'invasion russe et
une volonté de
repartir à zéro demande beaucoup
d'efforts se refaire une vie ça ne se
fait pas du jour au lendemain
mais quand les autres sont prêts à vous
aider c'est un peu plus facile
ici sébastien desrosiers radio-canada
mairie